-Are we ready?
-Yeah.
The professional.
Anti is ready.
We should
introduce ourselves,
-shouldn't we really?
-Oh God.
Right, start with you.
Diane Morgan.
-Playing?
-Kath.
Were you
going to say Dudley?
-Douglas…
-Douglas.
Douglas, I mean Kath.
Hi, I'm Ricky Gervais.
It shouldn't be that hard,
should it?
How would we ever
get anything done?
How did we film
three series of this?
We can't even
introduce ourselves.
I'm Ricky Gervais.
I play Tony.
I'm Jo Hartley. I play June.
I'm Tom Basden. I play Matt.
Tony Way, I play Lenny.
Let's do your personal…
onscreen moment
involving yourself.
-First.
-What do you mean personal?
What's your favourite
Kath scene?
Uh… maybe the snow globe?
Why is it empty?
What do you mean?
Well, usually,
there's like
a romantic scene
or a castle
or something inside.
Right.
Yeah, this is one of them
that you meant to put
a photo of loved one in,
but...
I haven't met anyone though.
Well, I got that from
a real story you told me.
-Yes, I know.
-On a podcast.
Yeah.
That really happened to me.
Yeah, which was a woman
you worked with, wasn't it?
Yeah. I had a job
in a worming tablet factory.
It's like Alan Bennett,
innit?
-And always I start.
-Yeah.
She got me
up to her office one day.
And she was
making me redundant.
And I noticed
she had an empty snow globe
and I said, "What…"--
One of those you meant
to put a picture in?
Yeah, she said "You meant
to put a picture in,
but I haven't
met anyone yet."
I know, awful!
And then she said,
"And you're fired."
Yeah.
Oh, by the way, yeah...
So, I got that,
changed it a bit.
Boom! Kevin Hart.
Bob's your uncle.
Favourite...
-That I'm in?
-Lenny. Yeah
I think it's the greatest
love-making scene
-ever committed to camera.
-Yeah.
Mum, have you seen
my juggling balls?
They're probably
where you left them, lovey.
It's funny
'cause it was still awkward.
Even though it was comedy
and there was no--
When you're close
to someone else
-in a scene. Very funny.
-It's just funny.
And then when that person's
onscreen child appears,
-there...
-Yeah.
...it was awkward.
Very funny.
Night, Lenny.
-Can I call you dad?
-Not at the moment.
First time we nailed it
without laughing.
You laughed, even though
you weren't in the scene.
Because I didn't realise
how awkward it was,
even as a joke.
Favourite Matt moment?
I think
probably my favourite,
certainly my favourite stuff
to shoot,
and probably
even to watch back,
is our sort of day
of racquet sports.
The kind of sequences
of table tennis
to tennis to squash.
That was just a huge amount
of fun to shoot, and yeah,
I love watching it.
When we were playing squash,
there was a point where
I think
we weren't really acting.
'Cause you was beating me,
I was getting wound up
about you beating me,
and then you were
winding me up even more.
-And that was...
-All goes in.
There's a lot of me
and Tony…
There's a lot me
that loves that stuff.
-The need to win. Yeah.
-Yeah.
When I first had
a game of squash, ever,
I'd had three pints.
It was where I used to work,
and then we found
there was a squash court.
I'd had three points,
and was…
like that, and I was playing
and all the foam and that...
And I just thought,
next time...
Then I got into squash
and I didn't have 3 pints...
'Cause I remember
reading that in the script,
you were having a pint
before squash.
And thinking, well,
that's insane, no one would,
-no one would do that.
-That's where I got it from.
-That's disgusting.
-That's right. Yeah, yeah.
And I think
I didn't throw up then,
but I did throw up once
when I was training
'cause I had a pint.
It's the perfect sport
to threw up during
'cause there's nowhere
to go.
You have to throw up
on the court...
And it's dangerous,
'cause it's slippy.
What if someone
just slips there.
I do like that bit
when I throw up
and I'm scooping
it away with my...
and you go,
"That's disgusting."
And I go, "What?"
And you go, "What!"
I mean, that's disgusting.
-What?
-What!
It's great, it's so great.
Favourite June moment?
There's loads.
Possibly my favourite
genuine beautiful moment
is when I speak to you
in season three.
Lisa was a beautiful person
that you spent
your life with.
She lives in your heart.
She only took out
the life insurance
so you didn't
have to worry about stuff.
You've given in that moment,
we was talking about
the other night at the...
you know,
with Penelope and yourself,
how well you write
for women, and it's lovely.
It was just
a nice moment that
and it made me happy
when I read the script
and I thought,
ah, he's really seen her
and it's like
she's like relief, really.
But she's
one of those steady...
But she's been through a lot
and so it's lovely when--
it's lovely
because she's doing it
for someone else.
I think you can
get away with anything,
in comedy and drama,
if the person is doing it
for the good
of someone else.
What's
your favourite moment?
My favourite moment...
Obviously, as an actor
and as a performance,
my favourite moments
are probably on the bench
or when I've got to cry
because you get
an adrenaline rush
and you've got to do that
and feel you've got one take
or I have, I can do it,
I can cry,
but I can only do it once
'cause then I feel better.
I hope she wasn't scared.
All she'd have wanted
was you with her at the end.
A man who's always joking
and always taking the piss.
When a man like that
suddenly cries,
it's all the more
heart breaking
'cause you think, oh God,
this is serious.
He's crying.
My other favourite moments
are the, and I'm not in them
but meant
to be filming them,
are the scenes with Lisa
because what I found is,
the more fun we were having
on the flashbacks,
we talked about this,
the more fun
those flashbacks were,
the more devastating it was.
'Cause you knew how much...
And you had to know
how much he'd lost
to forgive him
for all the terrible things
he then did
and said to people.
If he hadn't lost his wife
and you didn't know
about it...
he's just
a fucking psychopath.
I wanted the relationship
to be real.
I wanted it to be, as I say,
I didn't want it to be
a coffee advert.
I wanted it to be
a goofy, drunk, and funny...
The fact you shot it,
yourself, in the show...
Makes all the difference.
-…yeah, completely
-You cannot fake that.
You couldn't fake that.
The pair of you
are great together
and her laugh and the noise,
you know, when you shock her
with the noise with it.
Wow. Okay, let's move on
to my favourite moments
of all time, right.
Our favourite,
you don't
have to be in them,
but I think
my favourite onscreen moment
and behind the scenes
moment,
'cause it's sort of
bled into one,
was making him jump
with the air horn.
-I couldn't… couldn't do it.
-It went on all day.
I got it, I nailed it.
It was the best take,
and I then go,
"Let's do it again",
just for my amusement.
-Oh my God! Oh my God!
-Prat!
And then, I was,
I never stopped…
-No stunt training…
-Yeah. No. He fell. He...
Right, he fell
and hurt his elbow, right?
He really hurt his elbow
and said, "I banged my"...
…putting this forward
like it's a good thing.
I can sue you for that.
And I'm laughing, right,
I'm laughing in character,
and me, right?
And then, he goes,
"I hit my bloody elbow
on the dado rail",
and I fucking laughed again
and that's in.
That's in, my laugh,
when he...
-who says "dado rail"?
-I know, it's a funny word.
-What do you call it?
-…what do you call it.
Hurt my elbow as well.
There could be
another series each time
-of out-takes.
-Yeah, it's good.
So, your favourite moment
of all time.
The cake eating...
-What you do that for you?
-You look sad.
Oh, that's a waste.
Right, okay. Don't think
this is helping though.
Oh, look, it's all over you.
I liked it because it was
absolutely meaningless
-in terms of plot.
-Yeah.
-Added nothing to the plot.
-The cake…
Squash the face,
that's done.
Then, in they come.
Here we go. You like it.
-It's so good.
-What?
Can't understand
a word you're saying,
but I love watching you eat.
And it took two days,
if you remember?
'Cause we couldn't get it
on the first day, right?
And we nearly killed a man!
When Ethan is eating it,
he, you know...
He breathed in
a bit of cake.
-Yeah...
-He was sort of going...
-It was like a creamy…
-I know.
Well, I thought,
I'm gonna be on the news.
Someone's gonna die
and I said, "Okay, stop."
And we stopped it
and it was a Friday
and we picked it up again
on the Monday…
-Which never happens.
-…which never happens,
and we had to wear
the clothes
that we were covered in
for continuity.
So, we stank of off milk.
-And David kept ruining it.
-Yeah.
-Almost on purpose.
-He's hilarious.
He could've gone...
And they were going…
like that
and they'd
have to start again.
And then,
after about half an hour,
he was pretend to chew it
and then spitting it out.
Because he was gonna die
of cake.
He was amazing in it.
Favourite moment
of all time?
I mean, I think probably
the Ratty and Nonce stuff
'cause in both times
in the pub
and then when
they come in the office,
-it's just so enjoyable.
-And so not your people.
-No. No.
-Yeah.
-This is an office.
-Guys, this is an office.
Fucking hell,
Prince Andrew's kicking off.
You fucking rotta!
Get back in
your fucking box.
I'm not fucking about,
fucking about now.
He's just taking the piss,
don't worry about it.
Ratti and the Nonce podcast.
Namaste.
-They are like a whirlwind.
-Yeah.
And watching
everyone's reactions
and watch them as well
was wonderful.
Think it was a day or two
where we had them in
-and Colin and I think…
-And Brian.
…and Brian all in a row
and it was like
an onslaught.
It's like a comedy barrage.
-It was extraordinary.
-He's just incredible.
Yeah. Again,
is a work that kind of
when he comes in,
comes with that song,
-ad-libs that song…
-Bang, I'm taxi driver?
I didn't think it'd make it.
I thought that's mental.
Bang, bang,
I'm a taxi driver
I drive through the night
Picking up who I like
Bang, bang,
I'm a taxi driver
It was so good
and everyone just clapped.
Favourite of all time?
I love all the funny stuff.
There's too many.
I like the bath,
the bath on my first day
on set, season three...
-Oh!
-…with, that.
-Ethan in the bath.
-Yeah, brilliant. Again…
I mean what a trooper
though? What a trooper.
All right, boy?
-Mum!
-What, love?
-I'm having a bath.
-Good boy.
Bloody steamy in here,
innit?
Yeah, I told him
that he has it too hot.
Bad for his testicles.
Makes you sterile.
Do you mind?
Yeah,
they do look red, mate.
Oh yeah.
Put that cold
on them, James.
Honestly,
the anger, the anger.
A bloke in the bath
and people coming in
and talking
about his testicles
and he goes,
"I'm having a fucking bath!"
-And I'm offering him cake.
-Yeah!
-Want some cake, Brian?
-Ooh, yes, please.
-Thank you.
-James?
I'm having a fucking bath!
That a yes or no?
What kind of cake?
That's great when you said,
"You want some cake?" Yes!
Favourite moment
of all time?
I actually think it's...
you know the guy
that you go to visit
who collects
the birthday cards?
He's got like four
of the same birthday card.
Oh, yeah.
When I got the first one,
I thought
"That's a nice card."
And then I got the second
and I thought, that's funny.
Two of the same.
But when I got the third,
I thought,
"Well, what are the chances
of that?"
Astronomical.
And then the fourth… Wow!
I think he does it so well.
It's so funny
the way he goes…
And then, I've got another
and it goes on
and it gets funnier
and funnier.
And then, it's just… awful.
Denise
will be tickled by this is.
It's my wife.
She passed away last year.
Light of my life.
-Oh God, I'm in bits.
-Yeah.
That was the first time
I just literally lost it,
-was crying my eyes out.
-He was great, wasn't he?
Because
he had to be boring...
-Yeah!
-He had to be boring,
and then, you know,
absolutely…
-Unaware.
-And unaware, yeah.
And then,
what's good about that
is it makes Tony feel…
Selfish and spoilt.
Because this guy's gone
through exactly the same
and he's taking
the opposite.
And he doesn't
feel sorry for him at all.
Doesn't feel sorry.
You gotta keep going.
And he just says that,
he says that nervously,
the actor,
-he goes, gotta keep going.
-Oh, gosh.
'Cause he's even worried
about burdening someone.
But I think
what it also does,
'cause that's not the first
episode, isn't it, I think?
Yeah, it is. Yeah.
And it tells you,
that in the show,
that even if
people seem ridiculous,
that actually,
the point of it is
that there's humanity
to everybody
that we're gonna meet.
But those little things
keep you going.
Thanks everyone.
Thanks for watching.
-Watch it again.
-Bye